cuando fue la última vez que jugaron con
otros y no me refiero a sus sentimientos
independiente de si juegan o no hay una
serie de pre concepciones culturales
concebidas en torno al fuego
habitualmente negativas
en frases como
jugar es una pérdida de tiempo el juego
es sólo para niños jugar no tiene ningún
valor hay muchas cosas en juego juega
tela tú crees que esto es un juego
sí así que hoy día los invitamos a jugar
que levanta el índice de la mano derecha
toda persona que siga jugando por
diversión
en las manos arriba y eso es magnífico
porque a pesar de las concepciones
culturales en torno al juego hay una
serie de beneficios probados en torno a
este tanto a nivel individual como
interpersonal partiendo de la base de
que pensar como jugadores hace que
nuestros objetivos parezcan más
importantes estén más motivados y seamos
más perseverantes por ejemplo con las
listas de chequeo que se transforman en
los videojuegos en listas de misiones
porque con el objetivo de mantener al
jugador enganchado visibilizando su
progreso y dando recompensas apropiadas
para su esfuerzo por eso la próxima vez
que hagan una lista de chequeo
asegúrense de poner un premio
proporcional a su esfuerzo de forma que
activen el sistema de recompensas en su
cerebro
el juego también es una excelente
herramienta para conectar a las personas
piensan en las comunidades que se
generan en torno a las pichangas del
barrio o ustedes mismos cuando en verano
juegan a los naipes con la familia o
ejemplos más recientes como el día
internacional del juego de mesa que
organizamos en temuco junto a una tienda
de juegos local donde reunimos a más de
150 personas a jugar con desconocidos
pero que se relacionaron como si se
conocieran de toda la vida
y esto es porque los mamíferos
especialmente los primates estamos
predispuestos biológicamente para jugar
es un regalo de la evolución como dice
una famosa primatóloga chilena y
mediante este regalo adquirimos las
herramientas y las habilidades que
necesitamos para vincularnos con nuestro
entorno
desarrollamos cosas como la imaginación
la creatividad y la curiosidad
nosotros tenemos una experiencia con
estudiantes universitarios que estaban
viviendo la experiencia de entrar por
primera vez a la universidad imagínense
llegar a un lugar nuevo no conocer a
nadie tener una idea preconcebida de que
la universidad es seria académica
aburrida pero se la mostramos de la
forma que menos esperaban jugando
diseñamos un juego de cartas cooperativo
para los más de 2000 estudiantes que
entraron este año lo titulamos desafío
mechón y este representa lo que
significa vivir tu primer semestre con
los errores y aciertos que no suele
tener pero siempre acompañado a tus
amigos y hoy día les vamos a enseñar a
jugar desafío mechón
el juego comienza con cada jugador
robando una carta del mazo de cartas que
puede representar buenas ideas para la
universidad como estudiar una obra todos
los días o más las ideas como copiar en
la prueba
los que se ríen saben de qué estoy
hablando
en mi turno debo rodar una nueva carta
en este caso a otra mala idea estudiar
la noche antes
debo jugar una de las dos y como me
gusta dormir por las noches
voy a jugar copiar en la prueba
o no ahora mi compañero tiene más malas
ideas que buenas ideas en juego
y si sigues y hasta su siguiente turno
pierde y como el juego cooperativo todos
perdemos
ahí es cuando tengo que estar atento a
lo que está pasando al lado en mi turno
robo una carta más
u otra buena idea
en vez de jugarla para mí se lo voy a
jugar a mi amigo amigo mío ahora tus
buenas ideas compensan tus malas ideas
muchas gracias y el juego se acaba
cuando el mazo de cartas que representa
el semestre se termina y durante todo el
juego los jugadores lucharon para que
nadie perdiera
bien esa semestre han superado su primer
semestre
qué mayor desafío para un mechón que
dice
de esta forma fomentamos la cultura de
la colaboración obligando a los
participantes a estar atento de lo que
estaba pasando con sus compañeros al
lado intentarlo de nuevo si perdían
ayudarse entre sí y bueno apoyarse
mutuamente para lograr superar su primer
semestre esta experiencia nos dejó
muchos aprendizajes como equipo sobre
todo en las fases de diseño porque
aprendimos a valorar el error como una
fuente de crecimiento porque nos lleva
dando luces de cómo llegar al objetivo y
cómo estamos diseñando un juego la única
forma de aprender gada jugándolo cada
error era más entretenido que la
anterior también nos dimos cuenta que
cuando un juego es muy fácil de ganar no
es entretenido así que tuvimos que
calibrar un poco la dificultad para que
quienes jugarán se involucrarán con lo
que estaban haciendo si perdieran y
volvían a intentarlo y con la victoria
podían gozar
sigamos jugando que haga el símbolo de
la paz con la mano izquierda todo aquel
que haya aprendido algo solamente por
jugar
magnífico aunque no haya levantado la
mano izquierda cierto parecer el símbolo
de la paz estoy seguro que aquí todos y
todas han aprendido algo por jugar sino
como creen que aprendieron a interactuar
con su mundo cuando eran bebés y así hay
una serie de aprendizajes colaterales
que le llamamos solo por el hecho de
jugar
y por eso estamos acá hoy día porque
queremos contarles algunas nuestras
experiencias más significativas
cuando era niño
crecí en el pequeño pueblo de lago ranco
en una época pre internet imagínense es
y durante ese tiempo tuve mi primera
aproximación al idioma inglés
tenía que memorizar la canción de
titanic
para cantarlo en la siguiente clase
imagínense el panorama era un niño
pequeño
introvertido no me gustaba hablar en
público sigue sin gustarme
le tenía temor a la vergüenza le tenía
temor a el ridículo así que ese día
simplemente me tocó pasar adelante
cantar y me quedé en silencio
no hice absolutamente nada y aguantó
estoicamente la nota mínima
eso marcó el inicio de mi relación con
el idioma
pero después con la llegada de internet
y el paso de los años me frikismo subió
de nivel
y los vídeos juegos que me gustaban y
que me interesaban
tenían un solo problema
estaban en inglés
así que sin darme cuenta adquirí dos de
las habilidades que componen la
competencia de comunicación en inglés
aprendí a leer en inglés aprendí a
escuchar en inglés
pero hoy día a mis 32 años sigo sin
atreverme a hablar en inglés
y me imagino que como muchos aquí
aprendí más inglés jugando videojuegos
viendo series que en la sala de clases
hoy día el desafío que se me presenta es
poder expresarme en inglés y para eso ya
estoy desarrollando algunas estrategias
lúdicas pero la verdad es que no les voy
a decir más porque spoilers
desde que tengo 12 años que soy un
fanático de los juegos de rol donde
inventas un personaje que creas
historias improvisadas con tus amigos
el ejemplo más famoso es calabozos y
dragones también llamado daños and
dragons y siempre me encantó ser el
director de juego la persona que maneja
el flujo era narración el ritmo del
grupo interpreta los extras que se
encuentran con los jugadores pero por
otro lado siempre fui un maldito
introvertido por hacer razones de la
vida se me ocurrió que quería ser
profesor y no sabía desde el comienzo
cómo me iba a enfrentar a tantos
estudiantes
hasta que llegó el día
estaba solo con 40 pares de ojos atentos
a lo que iba a ser el practicante
tenía la uat apretada me corría la gota
y cuando empecé a hablar como que me
sentí raro y así como que de repente de
la nada hablando
subí de nivel
la barrita de experiencia en mi cabeza
se estuvo llegando durante todos esos
años por jugar rol y en ese entonces en
ese preciso momento pasé de ser de un
estudiante en práctica al profesor nivel
hasta hace algunos años atrás veía el
juego el estudio y el trabajo como cosas
separadas y no se mezclan
porque les cuento esto
porque personalmente me cuesta mucho
motivarme con las cosas esa actitud de
para que cuando algo no tiene sentido
para mí me ha hecho perder oportunidades
y me ha hecho dejar cosas inconclusas
como la vez que abandona el magíster
cuando estaba a punto de terminar la
tesis a punto terminó en la tesis
porque desean encontrarle sentido
hoy estoy aprendiendo a transferir y a
utilizar metodologías lúdicas para
involucrarme con aquellas cosas que me
aburren con aquellas cosas que no me
motivan y estoy transfiriendo esta
mentalidad lúdica a esferas de mi vida
que antes no hubiese imaginado para
poder seguir avanzando
desde que tengo memoria que me cuesta
conectar con las personas quienes me
conocen lo saben
es como si tuviera un freno dentro que
me impide decir todo lo que tengo que
decir
porque son los juegos tan importantes
para mí entonces porque aquellos que te
hacen interactuar como los juegos de rol
o los de tablero
se han convertido en un verdadero acceso
directo de lo que hay dentro de mí para
los demás
he llegado a sentir que una tarde de
juegos es tan reconfortante para el alma
que una conversación profunda con amigos
y es por eso que estamos aquí
convencidos de que el juego no solamente
una herramienta para desarrollar
habilidades sino que para el crecimiento
personal
y no somos los únicos que piensan así en
este momento en chile están surgiendo
una serie de iniciativas que revalorizan
el fuego como algo útil como algo
necesario y vital para nuestra vida ya
sea en contextos cotidianos
en contextos educativos en contextos
laborales o en espacios no
convencionales quien se iba a imaginar
15 años atrás que en chile habrían
tantas editoriales de juegos de mesa y
juegos de vídeo incluso en algunas
partes del país abrieron carreras para
diseñar videojuegos
y le damos las gracias a todos ellos
porque hacen que el país vaya subiendo
de nivel y se convierta de a poco en
chile lúdico
y por eso estamos nosotros aquí hoy día
motivados y conectándonos con ustedes
porque el fuego
es vital para nuestras vidas es algo
sumamente importante así que los
invitamos a seguir jugando pero el resto
de sus días a recordarles que jugar es
para todas las edades que el juego es el
entorno natural del aprendizaje que en
esta vida hay que jugársela
y el fuego tienen que tomárselo en serio
que se siguen jugando van a subir de
nivel ahora la pelota está de tu lado de
la cancha gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]